Welcome back everyone it's Charlie this will be
my Joker 2 first look video Todd Phillips just
started filming the movie he dropped the first
scene so we'll break it all down also explain
how this fits into James Gunn's plan for the next
10 year of DC movies because there's so much chaos
happening with all the movies the recasting the
soft rebooting of the entire DC EU because it's a
developing situation I will be doing videos for
all this stuff so be sure to subscribe to get
everything the big thing you may have seen people
posting about recently all over your feeds is that
Todd Phillips just started filming Joker two this
is the first scene with Joaquin Phoenix's Joker
character getting a shave notice his trademark
emaciated look like he gained a lot of weight
after they filmed the first movie because he lost
so much weight like a crazy amount of weight it
was meant to play into the sort of unhealthy Vibe
of the character like he was just living a very
unhealthy lifestyle because of everything that
had been happening to him and everything he'd
been going through clearly things have not gotten
better with him being inside Arkham Asylum he
looks nonetheless for where he's still inside
Arkham Asylum if you couldn't tell while he's
being shaved here this is a prison guard doing
the actual shaving holding his head down just in
case he tries to escape while they're actually
holding a sharp razor to his neck the way that
James Gunn and the other Warner Brothers people
talked about the movie they aren't planning on
touching what Todd Phillips is doing with
the Joker movie at all it's still going to
be in its own alternate universe I think that's
just because the first movie did so well had it
not been so successful they probably would have
soft rebooted that too they're getting the same
treatment that Matt Reeves is getting with his
Batman franchise Robert Pattinson's Batman all
those spin-offs those are also being currently
treated like it's his own alternate continuity
like these two different franchises are happening
on Alternate universes from the main Justice
League Earth that will be the one that they soft
reboot Todd Phillips also recently dropped a
teaser trailer for Joker too so they're actually
going full steam ahead with the production there
was a title reveal and the full script like it's
basically good to go because they're getting ready
to film it the title is pronounced Joker Folie
Au Duex its French for Joker shared Madness as
in Joker shared psychotic episode it's determined
psychology used to describe when multiple people
share the same delusion the same psychotic
episode this also confirms now that the title
shared delusions so to speak refers to the shared
delusion that joker will share with Doctor harleen
quinzel during his stay at Arkham Asylum that a
lot of reports that say that most of the movie
will take place in and around Arkham Asylum
so it'll deal with the development of their
relationship like how he meets her for the first
time how she eventually falls in love with him and
eventually he winds up twisting her to the dark
side so to speak they've kind of addressed that
in previous Batman projects like they did a little
bit during the previous Suicide Squad movies with
the Margot Robbie version of Harley Quinn we saw
a little bit of her origin story as Harley Quinn
it sounds like a lot of this movie is just going
to be a much bigger version of that also because
it's still going to be relatively low budget
it makes sense that they would keep a lot of
it in and around Arkham Asylum it'll be really
interesting to see what she looks like compared
to the Margot Robbie version of Harley Quinn I
had to cut out a little bit of the music from
the teaser trailer just for copyright reasons but
this is what the actual audio sounds like on it
it's playing that classic song cheek to cheek
which is just meant to reference the context
of their relationship like this is happening
in Arkham Asylum like it's a reference to the
fantasy that is taking place in his head you're
never quite sure if what's happening is really
happening or if it's just happening inside his
head and now obviously because it's a shared
delusion is it happening inside her head as well
the fun fact about the Joker serum too is that
it's actually derived from the Scarecrow fear
toxin but we haven't had the Scarecrow inside
the Joaquin Phoenix Joker Universe yet and even
though it is possible that he could use some
version of The Joker serum during this Joker
sequel I don't think they're going to play it
that way I think they'll keep it in the realm of
metaphor when he talks about sharing his Madness
with everyone like through his actions through
the media people will watch it like the people
who are writing and it'll just get crazier and
crazier and crazier and he'll start to win them
over through his actions and they will then begin
to share in his Madness it's not like he's gonna
go around dumping a bunch of fear toxin or Joker
toxin into the water supply that's the really
cool the really Insidious thing about the first
Joker movie is that he doesn't need any kind of
Joker toxin like that it's all about the role of
the media and all this like in the case of the
first movie it was his broadcast at the end that
helped push his exploits to Legendary status but
at the time he was already building on an existing
system of riots that all the people in Gotham had
been upset about the current Administration
the growing problems in the city the whole
inequality between the common people who were
riding in the ultra rich people represented by
Thomas Wayne Bruce Wayne's family he was in the
middle of running for mayor and there were these
escalating series of riots throughout the movie
as things got crazier and crazier and crazier
public outcries during his appearances eventually
before he went full Joker at the end of the movie
he called The Crowd a bunch of clowns so already
things were going really crazy in the city and
what was happening with the joker just kind of
tipped that over the edge the whole thing with
him secretly being Thomas Wayne's son I think
was actually a bit of a misdirect but the way
the movie plays it they want to be kind of
ambiguous about it because you're meant to
be viewing everything in the film from Arthur's
perspective so as he descends into madness you're
meant to see things get crazier and weirder
and weirder like they wanted you to feel as
if there might have been a possibility that he was
Thomas Wayne's son and they never confirmed that
it wasn't true even though they implied that it
was all just this big delusion in reality I think
that his mother had suffered from mental delusions
like he does in the movie like she had had mental
episodes when she was younger and she just fell in
love with Thomas Wayne when her family was working
at his mansion and started to get creepy at his
house and then they just imply that his family
kind of pushed her family out the door like okay
you go off on your own no more working for us and
she just descended into a form of Madness and
just came up with this delusion that she had
been in relationship with Thomas Wayne when that
really wasn't the case so he's not really Thomas
Wayne's son but during the movie you notice even
after Thomas Wayne yells at him and they have that
episode together that big encounter he calls him
a crazy person Arthur does not stop believing that
it's true he's still obsessed with the wanes so
the idea is that he had played a party clown and
Thomas Wayne had called the people like him like
the Lower Class People a bunch of clowns acting
crazy he started to feel like his life was a
joke eventually he just kind of owns all that
by wearing the name as his own mantle calling
himself The Joker Matt Reeves actually had his
version of The Barry kyokin Joker in the Batman
movie kind of say something similar like it's not
so bad being a clown the big difference during the
Batman movie though is the ages of the Batman and
the Joker and the Joker is in prison and Arkham
Asylum because Batman put him there they released
a deleted scene that was meant to be on the one
year anniversary of him putting him in prison
so the Barry kilkin Joker was joking about that
with him like isn't it our anniversary present
oh sorry anniversary isn't it so if it wasn't
clear now obviously Matt Reeves has confirmed that
the Joker in his universe is not going to be the
Joaquin Phoenix version of Joker and even though
they are doing all this crazy Multiverse stuff
with The Flash movie The Joaquin Phoenix Joker
movie will still be set in an alternate universe
it's still going to be rated R it's still going
to be part of DC's Black Label which is what
they're using for their darker more hardcore
films especially ones that are set in alternate
universes that aren't necessarily connected to
all the big dceu stuff most of the plot details
are being kept in an underground bunker as you
would expect but based on what both Phillips and
Phoenix had said previously the movie isn't going
to have like a massive time Jump the original
movie took place during 1981 Joaquin Phoenix is
in his 50s in present day in real world but he was
playing a 30 40-something Joker so any references
to Batman or any of the other pre-existing DC
characters in The Joker sequel is just meant to
be a coincidence or in the case of this version
of Batman just a totally new different version
of Batman the Joker sequels mostly just meant to
move forward a little in the timeline to the next
logical event in Gotham so Bruce Wayne would
still be a child living with Alfred he'd be a
little bit older but still be a child and there
wouldn't be a bunch of Batman stuff happening
yet the other really big change that you probably
just heard about that I mentioned earlier was Todd
Phillips separately being asked by the new powers
that be at DC at Warner Brothers to come in and
advise on doing more films kind of like the Joker
in the same vein like talking about more DC Black
Label types of movies that means more mid-budget
movies like movies that are closer to like 90 100
million dollars about villain characters different
from what you would think of your traditional big
superhero type of DC film like a Batman movie what
probably changed recently about that is that James
Gunn is probably talking to him about potentially
doing more stuff like that but they're trying to
figure out how that's going to fit with his new
plan for the next 10 years of the main line of
DC movies Matt Reeves has talked about doing lots
of spin-offs for his characters like there's the
Arkham Asylum TV show there's the other Batman
based TV shows on the Robert Pattinson version of
Batman that's not meant to be DC Black Label stuff
all the stuff that Todd Phillips would be doing or
helping advisor producing at Warner Brothers if
other directors come on to do them is meant to
be a different line of continuity personally I
actually think that's been one of DC's strengths
they just announced that Marvel is finally doing a
Thunderbolts movie and they said that they pitched
it kind of like the Marvel version of a Suicide
Squad film one of DC's big advantages over Marvel
the past couple years has been their willingness
to do R-rated villain based films this also kind
of gets into what's going on with the bloodbath
that was happening at HBO Max recently with all
the cancellations of TV shows and movies what they
were mostly canceling with like the Batgirl movie
for instance is movies that they had originally
just exclusively made for HBO backs like they're
not doing that anymore no more mid budget just
for HBO max they're just doing theatrical films
now and that's basically what Todd Phillips plan
always was like this was always going to be a
theatrical Joker 2 movie all the DC Black Label
stuff that he might wind up doing in the future
that's all intended for a theater release what
will happen though is that James Gunn is making
his big presentation about the next 10 years of
DC movies to the Warner Brothers board the new
CEO and once that happens he'll probably make
those plans public on his Twitter account or
at least some of the plans like I said it is a
developing situation so we will continue to hear
about more changes coming up everyone click here
to learn about the Batman Beyond movie they were
making with Michael Keaton and click here for my
Guardians of the Galaxy 3 trailer video in Easter
eggs thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe and I'll see you guys in the next one!